there's never been a better time to be a
sellout most of 2021's highest paid
musicians earned their way into the
ranks by selling all or pieces of their
music catalogs often for nine figures
other top earners sold production
studios cashed in on vintage tv shows or
hulk champagne tequila or sneakers this
trend is most apparent in our number two
lister bruce springsteen the boss sold
the masters in publishing rights to all
his recorded music and songwriting to
sony music group in december for what
sources say was almost 500 million
dollars forbes estimates that brings his
lifetime earnings to at least one
billion dollars before taxes
other classic acts to sell their
lucrative music catalogs in 2021 include
bob dylan paul simon and neil young who
hauled in a combined 500 million dollars
before fees enough for each to earn a
spot in this year's rankings their giant
paydays have as much to do with estate
planning as timeless songs all of these
rockers are in their 70s and 80s so they
get a guaranteed nest egg and an income
alternative to touring catalog sales are
also a smart way to cash in during a
bull market for music and get ahead of
likely higher tax rates
the buyers meanwhile are betting on a
continued expansion of digital content
and the need for material whose
popularity is timeless but the
entertainer who took this year's number
one spot is lord of the rings director
peter jackson he became a billionaire in
november when he sold part of his visual
effects firm weta digital to unity
software for 1.6 billion dollars about
40 of it in cash
reese witherspoon also sold part of her
production studio hello sunshine at a
900 million dollar valuation in august
combined with earnings from her apple tv
plus show the morning show witherspoon
pulled down 115 million dollars in 2021
landing her at number 12 on our list
hip hop mogul jay-z also sold stakes in
music streamer title and the armand de
bruyneak champagne brand which helped
bring him 340 million dollars and a spot
at number three on our list dwayne the
rock johnson lands at number 4 with 270
million dollars about 25 of his earnings
came from starring roles in films like
jungle cruise and red notice most of the
rest came from his buzzy tequila brand
taramana rapper kanye west is number
five with 235 million dollars much of
which he made from his multi-year deal
to design yeezy sneakers for adidas his
first easy items for the gap hit shelves
last year and quickly sold out
less popular in 2021 original content
less than a third of our listers made
the bulk of their income from fresh
content such as shonda rhimes who landed
at number 18 with 81 million dollars she
re-upped with netflix in july for four
more years but still receives hefty
residuals from grey's anatomy
[Music]
you